we're going to begin this hour with an
incredible story of determination that
led to a life-changing Discovery Deanna
schrodes who was adopted as a baby was
building a family in Florida while at
the same time trying to learn about her
own Origins so after years of searching
schrodes met her biological mom who died
before revealing the identity of her
biological father our lead National
correspondent that's David begno spoke
with schrodes about getting answers and
answering a stranger's prayers in the
process
the life story of Deanna schrodes was a
story without a beginning
at least she didn't know the beginning
but she was determined to find out I
have to know where I started and I have
to know who else out there is a part of
me that desire never never left schrodes
was adopted as an infant she was 27
years old when she found her biological
mom she was not open to meeting me and
then I went and met her personally I
just showed up knocked on the door so
you meet her and you guys end up having
a relationship for how many years 20
years until she died you had one
question for your mother which you kept
asking yeah and it was who is my father
and her answer was I'm gonna go to the
Grave with the name had no idea she was
sick had no idea that there was cancer
Brewing weeks later she was diagnosed
and a couple months later she was dead
she took it to the group she took it
right to the Grave Just give me a call
now the story almost ended right there
but her mom did tell her two important
things about her dad he was Greek and
from Richmond Virginia so she set out
creating a private Facebook group
finding Mr Greek she gathered a group of
friends and volunteers who would help
search for him and she signed up for
multiple DNA Registries hoping that
science would lead her to her father how
many years do they try to find Mr Greek
well it's been 10 years I got maybe five
matches on my father's side so I'm like
this is terrible like we don't have
anything to work with here on the DNA
side just open yourself up for just a
new level of healing and restoration in
your life she is an ordained minister so
she prayed a lot
I told my husband I told my best friend
Lara I said listen guys you might think
I'm crazy but I was in prayer
God spoke this to me your father's name
is Gus well sure enough in May of this
year after nearly a lifetime of
wondering her prayers were answered
there was a match to a cousin she never
knew she had I reached out to this
cousin and I said we've just matched on
23andMe and he said I think you're my
uncle Gus's daughter and I said
I think that too
[Music]
his name is Gus Gus Nicholas 92 years
old he lived in Richmond all his life a
bachelor who was never married he was a
retired ballroom dance instructor I
prepared myself to find a grave and I
now found a person and it was just
absolutely mind-blowing couldn't believe
that I had found a person schrodes
called him the very next day my heart
was beating out of my chest I was like
what is this going to be like and is he
going to accept me is he going to want
to see me when I found him he was so
excited to be found he said I woke up
this morning
and I was alone now this afternoon I
have a daughter I have a son-in-law I
have three grandchildren I have great
grandchildren he said I'm not alone in
the world anymore and I said no you're
not you're not within a week she was at
Gus's bedside while I'm here
I'm glad I'm here too as it turns out
just four months before they met Gus had
fallen at home he was found lying on the
floor he could no longer care for
himself so the state placed him in a
nursing home and that's where they first
met Gus would say to me please don't let
me die in here don't let me die in here
and I said you know what I'm going to
make sure yes they are father and
daughter but still strangers which makes
what happened next absolutely remarkable
Deanna said to Gus would you like to
come and live with me
to which Gus responded how soon can we
go
and so 56 years after she was adopted
and 75 short days after she first called
him
schrodes and her husband Pastor Larry
schrodes took Nicholas out of that
nursing home and drove him to their home
right outside Tampa Florida
they now provide for him full time
she cooks his meals Greek he always
prefers
and she feeds them to him
her guest room is now his bedroom
there are the mementos that he asked her
to bring from the Richmond home
his trophies dancing shoes favorite hat
and a picture from the good old days
I love you so much
92 years of memories are packed into
this 80 square foot room it is just big
enough for his hospital bed but intimate
enough for the conversations they have I
knew your mama for 60 some years
Hi Gus I even got a chance to say hello
how does it feel to have your daughter
find you
it felt good yeah I just found my
daughter my daughter failed me she found
you
to the man who gave her life she is
prepared to give back to him until the
end of his she's asked just one thing of
him
will you tell me all about you it is the
most worthwhile thing I've ever done in
my life it's the hardest thing it's the
most worthwhile thing
it's the most incredible Miracle I've
ever had the privilege to live out
I'm living the dream isn't that
wonderful yes
David what a story I mean she took such
a risk just knocking on the mother's
door saying here I am and then to find
Gus I believe that stuff happens where
you hear a voice and it tells you
something and it turns out to be the
real thing and it's Gus
it's amazing I have to tell you guys I
heard this story on a Saturday morning
from a viewer who reached out to me and
said David you got to hear this story I
called her right away and two hours
later I said if I can convince my bosses
to let me go do this story we'll be
there right away and sure enough we did
it is a remarkable the journey the
determination she had and to find that
man and then say let me take care of you
thank you yeah I was just so moved by it
I love him laying in the bed saying did
you have the orange juice already they
have such a connection and I can't help
but notice that sign above the bed too
that says give it to God and go to sleep
I know you notice no doubt David to God
and go to sleep I'm curious did Deanna
ever find out why her mom wanted to go
to the Grave with Gus's name oh I knew
somebody would ask that good question
she doesn't know for sure she thinks
it's because her mom uh God Rest her
soul didn't really want to share her
with Gus there may have been some
resentment between the two of them
dating back to when they first met and
she that's why her mom wanted to keep it
a secret
did Gus even know that she existed did
he know
he did my understanding is he did
oh wow well I'm glad they found each
other and certainly the way they found
each other right on time huh yeah we
love it when viewers send you story
ideas and we really love it sign off on
it keep them coming David reads his DMS
love the Happy Endings right yes we love
a happy ending David becknow thank you
very much my friend see you again soon